we're going to talk about face coverings
here in just a second with cbs news
medical contributor dr david agus who
joins us
with more on the coronavirus but dr agus
i want to start with a question that
tens of millions of parents
are asking and wondering about and that
is should kids go back to school the cdc
as michael noted released that new
guidance this week
talking about the importance of having
kids in classrooms can it be done safely
should it be done thank you jeff
it's a difficult time because there is
no one-size-fits-all policy and
obviously the cdc just
put out a one-size-fits-all policy it is
going to depend
what is the incident rate in the area
you live if you're in an area
where there's a significant number of
cases and it's going up
i'd be very cautious about what's going
on in school my hope is
most school districts make it mandated
to wear a mask
if you wear a mask there is dramatically
less spread
in the classroom and within students and
that's going to be critical going
forward
the policies that were put out by the
cdc are
generic and we certainly need more
prescriptive guidance for school
students because
school districts what to do students
parents have to make critical decisions
over the next several weeks
about what to do in the fall you
mentioned the mass there it seems like
everything comes back to two things
masks and testing and we've seen delays
in getting test results recently give us
some sense
as we move forward in the next month
where should we be testing wise
you know when you test somebody you then
can go back and say hey
you're positive let me see who you spoke
to over the last two days we call that
social tracing and we can talk to those
individuals
because they have been exposed to the
virus but when there's a delay of five
six seven eight days on testing
going back really is meaningless because
those people
who have been exposed can expose many
others during that period
so we have to do testing where we can
give results within 24 hours or so
we have to be able to scale testing
especially in areas where it's harder
hit
where there are lines to get testing and
then days to get result that's not
acceptable
we need testing and then at the same
time we have to mandate
mandate in the country that we wear mass
we don't like that
people are getting upset over that but
we're going to look back a month or two
from now and say
i wish we did it earlier because it's
going to have to happen
dr regas how hopeful are you or when do
you think a vaccine i know they're in
stage 3
in some of these trials for a potential
vaccine how quickly do you think that
happens
phase three not stage three it's not a
play but
um i'm just joking obviously the uh what
duly noted
we have several of them in face we have
several of them in phase three clinical
trials
across the globe my hope is that some of
the phase three trials that started
earlier especially in countries like
brazil and south africa
will yield results soon it's the same
vaccine in all of these countries
will yield results that we can build on
our phase threes are just beginning
the end of the month but if those
results come true and there
are statistical difference we can lower
symptoms from the virus by at least
50 percent i'm hoping 70 percent we
could have a vaccine in the early fall
well we certainly wish this was a play
the entire thing we would put a wrap on
it kick it off broadway and never see it
again
dr david agus thank you very much